everybody welcome to citizen by CNN I'm Christine
romans. I'm the host of early start. You have
to get up early to see that five a.m. To six
a.m. Eastern time where we sort of start CNN's
programming for the day and I'm also the chief
business correspondent and I'm really delighted
to be moderating this afternoon. A discussion
about inflation jobs and the economy and what
it all means heading into the midterms. You
can see on your screen with me Paula Monica,
Phil Mattingly and Vanessa Jurkovic, all of
them have been covering different angles of
this this week as we're heading into what?
Just 50 some odd days until the mid terms.
This is a super important topic both of course
for your pocketbook, for your investments,
for your portfolio and for your vote. Right.
Um So we're going to dig into all of it. Um
and also of course we want to be answering
your questions as well. So bring those questions
and we've already got a few on deck. But I
want to start with Paula Monica. First the
big story this week inflation rearing its
ugly head again. Or actually maybe it never
really started stop roaring when you look
at have this chart for you. You look at consumer
prices and you look at producer prices, two
new pieces of data we've had over the last
24 hours, you know that consumer price number,
the bottom line kind of freaked everybody
out the top line though. Not quite as bad
Paula Monica. The state of inflation is fill
in the blank. Not not going away anytime soon
unfortunately. And I think that's the problem?
There had been a lot of hopes that all of
these rate hikes that the Federal Reserve
has already done would start to show a more
tangible impact on consumer prices and have
having them come down. And while some prices
notably energy have been cut recently, which
is good news for consumers, you haven't seen
things like food and other very important
consumer items. The price of their hasn't
gone down nearly as dramatically. And in some
cases they're still going up pretty sharply.
So I think that is causing alarm bells among
consumers and investors as well because now
all of a sudden you have people talking about
the Federal Reserve potentially raising rates
by a full percentage point next week, which
is something that Christine you. And I know
they haven't done in the modern era, which
is, you know, pretty much since you and I
have been. I know, I mean it is really shocking
just what they've done so far is dramatic.
They haven't seen that since the early 1990s,
you mentioned those grocery store prices,
eggs up 39% flour up 23%, this is year over
year, 17% more expensive for milk. So Phil
Mattingly, I mean I felt like the falling
gas prices was a tailwind for the White House
and for democrats heading into the midterms,
but any time you're going to the grocery store
even paying your rent, these inflation numbers
are still still a problem. What does that
mean for the White House? Look it's a huge
problem and it's one they've obviously been
keenly aware of now for the better part of
a year. Um And I think one of the hardest
things when you talk to White House officials
particularly on the economic team is that
there's no real roadmap here at this point.
Right, When is the last time the economy has
been coming out of a once in a century pandemic?
How do you tie things together? What are the
indicators you're looking at? And what is
the traditional trajectory that should be
followed in this moment? And there really
isn't one, you know, if you look at the street
reaction yesterday to the C. P. I. Report
that tells you everything you need to know
Wall Street, he was also expecting a much
friendlier report in terms of inflation deceleration,
not just the White House. Um And so I think
what you see right now is a very complicated
dynamic. And yesterday was actually a beautiful
window into that where you had the president
on the south lawn with thousands of people
there holding a celebration for really the
cornerstone legislative achievement uh aptly
termed the inflation reduction act at the
same exact time. There is a split screen moment
where the markets closed and they're down
1300 points. Um which is kind of how they're
grappling with this right now inflation is
not going away. Their hope is that it decelerates
obviously gas prices being down consistently
over the course of 90 days is a central point
for them. Um But the reality right now is
This is a major problem. The question becomes,
if people feel like there's progress, I'll
just one last thing and I'll stop ranting,
Christine, uh there is a, there is a line
inside the White House right now, when you
talk to officials who point to Reagan in 84,
not Reagan in the midterms, but Reagan in
84 where obviously coming off a major significant
inflation crisis still kind of in the midst
of one inflation was still I think about 7%
around election day. Um but it had had a trend
line just consistently downward and that's
what they're looking for, right? They want
trajectory and they want to be able to point
to the fact that things are getting better
if they no longer have the ability to say
things are getting better. That is a major
problem and very much undercuts the progress
that they believe has been made and a rather
steady economy and a number of different other
factors. Yeah, and a very strong job market
which which we'll get to in a minute. But
in this whole soup now Vanessa enter the possibility
of a rail strike 30% of America's goods are
traveled traveled by the rail lines and it
hasn't happened yet But already you're seeing
Amtrak for example, spend some, you know,
long haul routes because they don't know exactly
what's gonna be happening on those rail lines
and you know, already orders of things that
are for example, you know, chemicals and things
that you can't have sitting on on an empty
rail rail, you know, railtrack, those have
already stopped. So where are we on this rail
problem? Well, this will no doubt tiddly be
unwelcome news for both the administration
and the american people if this happens because
we're already in a moment as as uh, you know,
Phil and paul have mentioned, you know, of
of still grappling with high inflation. So
if this rail strike goes through, if this
happens, which so far there's not a lot of
movement on both sides between the unions.
Um, and the rail lines, that's why they were
called to Washington D. C. Right now, that's
why Secretary of Labor marty Walsh has them
in a room right now. Um, there's no end to
negotiations today. They're not saying we're
ending at five PM everybody goes home. I mean,
the administration is really trying to get
a deal Peeked out in this sort of 11th hour,
but this will undoubtedly be a problem for
the economy. I mean if there are no conductors,
no engineers running these trains, the trains
are not moving and they carry everything from
auto parts to ethanol, which is used to make
gasoline to food crops, that farmers are growing
that need to get to processing facilities
to make cheerios and bread. And if that's
not happening, prices on gas prices on food,
retail goods and as you mentioned, commuter
lines are going to be impacted because a lot
of the nation's commuter lines actually share
freight lines. And if the freight trains aren't
moving, the commuter trains are not moving.
So that is going to really play into sort
of this readjustment of the american people
once again, trying to figure out how to get
around, trying to understand why their costs
are starting to go up. And I just want to
point out this is not gonna happen, you know,
days into this strike if if it does happen
on friday, it's gonna be a week or longer
after that. That will really start to see
these economic impacts, but no one is, no
one is loving that this is happening right
now. And certainly everyone is holding their
breath at the moment. One of the things that's
a sticking point here, the different kinds
of unions that work for the railroads, but
you have these conductors and engineers who
are the rasta ring system, they're on call
basically seven days a week, right. And I
feel like we're entering a moment and I guess
I'll put this to paul where we have a very
tight labor market and for the first time,
certainly since I've been covering business
news and labor mar worker has the upper hand
two years out of a pandemic. We have seen
the quiet quitting, the great resignation.
People who have the means to retire or step
back are doing that and guess what? Those
happen to be engineers and conductors. We
have a labor issue that's here, not, not,
not just labor unions, but but we have a very
tight labor market hall. Yeah, that is a good
bit of news. Obviously for many americans
who have probably for decades been longing
to have a little bit more of an upper hand
with regards to negotiations with their employers.
But of course that is a problem for the american
economy in that wages have risen dramatically
and that is of course one of the issues that
is fueling all these inflation pressures,
It's not just wages, obviously it's also some
of the supply chain snarls that we've had
globally over the past year coming out of
the pandemic and that has led to higher prices
also. But I think that is one issue that you
don't want to be glib and say, wouldn't it
be nice if people weren't making as much money
is that inflation wouldn't be as significant
of a problem. But in some respects the fact
that wages have gone up this sharply, it is
a conundrum to use an old word that Alan Greenspan,
former Fed chair was fond of for central bankers
right now, what can you you do in this environment
raise rates sharply, which probably will lead
to a slowing economy and to some respects,
the Fed wants the economy to cool, but they
don't want the housing market to collapse.
No one wants a 2008 type scenario where banks
have bad loans on their books all of a sudden
and we're talking about great recession two
point oh, but if things go on like this, the
economy inevitably would overheat and that
could create even bigger issues that no central
banker can solve. You bring in the maestro.
You know, there's another former Fed chief
paul Volcker, um you know, who had to really
crank up interest rates to try to, you know,
break the back of stagflation. We should point
out dramatically. The White House has done
this many times when, you know, we talked
to the, you know, the White House economic
team Both on the record and off the record,
that the US consumer balance sheets are much
better today than they were before the 2000
and 2009 crisis. There's just no question
about that and all that, that money in COVID
that prevented a depression that now might
be splashing around and helping you know,
fuel this inflation. A lot of that money is
still in the pockets of American consumers
and their bank accounts. So the American consumer
is in much better shape today with all of
these uncertainties. AM I right? Yeah. Look,
I mean, contrary to popular belief, two things
can be true here. One, the economic recovery
in the wake of the pandemic has been so much
so dramatically better than it was in the
wake of the great recession. In terms of the
limits of scarring the long term implications
for the economy, people's ability not just
to get back to work, but as you noted, their
uh their credit card balances, what's in their
bank account, an entirely different place.
And yet uh some of the assistance that was
sent out, particularly, I'm thinking of some
of the stimulus checks are an accelerant or
have been fueling at least some element of
the inflation increase. I think the interesting
thing when you talk to White House officials
here is this complicated political balance
that they have and messaging balance, which
is acknowledge the fact that when food prices
are where they are right now, that is a real
problem for real people uh that they are experiencing
every day and you cannot ignore that. And
you cannot act like you don't see it and you
can't act like you're not trying to pursue
policies that would address it. Uh Another
element of that is it's the Feds purview,
right? The White House isn't signing a bunch
of major new uh stimulus short term spending
legislation at this moment in time. That's
the Fed's job. So what can the White House
do? Well, what the White House can do is point
to the legislation, they've been acted up
to this point that has g even a pretty significant
buffer coming out of such a significant downturn
that we probably there's a lot of historical
precedent for um whether or not that resonates
with people I think is the big question because
when you look at the numbers right now and
you look at people's use of the economy, the
short answer is it's not really resonating.
Yeah it's not you know Vanessa, you've talked
to have done so many packages as we call it
in T. V. Land right? We call them packages.
And you go out in the field and you talk to
people about their financial situation. You
try to tell their story. And I've been watching
you tell those stories and I'm struck by a
couple of things. Um the lack of child care
worker, there's a lack of good pay and childcare
which prevents people from getting childcare,
which prevents more people, especially women
getting back into the labor force, which then
would of course help solve this problem of
a too tight labor force. Tell me a little
bit about what people have been telling you
about what it's like paycheck to paycheck
on the front lines. And I think in that package
that I did about childcare, I use the term
vicious cycle because that is what it feels
like for for so many women in these childcare
uh predicaments. But you know, I think we're
at a moment where people are just trying to
understand what's going on. We're talking
about the economy, we're talking about inflation,
we're talking about jobs, but at sort of a
basic level people are, are really trying
to understand why it costs so much more to
send their Children to get to daycare, but
why the daycare workers are not making uh
you know, as much money as they should be
and that their wages are not sort of rising
in line with inflation and what it costs to
send their Children to daycare. I mean they're
really just trying to make sense of it all
and they're sort of looking around thinking,
well who's going to fix this? And a lot of
what I talk about with them is is who are
you looking to? And and they don't really
know who to look to. I mean, as Phil mentioned,
there's, you know, there's not a whole lot
the president can do except for, you know,
messaging about different bills he's passed.
Um you know, when you try to talk about the
Federal reserve, you know, that seems just
so you know out there for folks because they
want to be, He sort of listened to and helped
in the moment. They want to understand why
their $60 budget at the grocery store that
they used to have is now buying them less.
They want to understand why they are having
to ration filling up at the pump and I think
it's just this delicate balance between just
trying to get through the day. But also understand,
I mean how they can, can re budget and make
it work for their family, you know, and Phil
I think it's interesting because the White
House has been trying to take a victory lap
on some of this legislation. But the things
that Vanessa and I are talking about right
here, expanded child tax credits, that was
something that was meant to put money in the
pockets of those families right to help them.
The President wanted and build back better.
He really he wanted to have um, he wanted
to have universal pre K for example, which
would help with this and investments in child
care. So on the one hand, the President's
trying to point to legislative achievements.
But on the other hand, things that he couldn't
get through are still a burden for american
families right now. Yeah, it's so fascinating.
And I uh I concur with you on somebody who's
watched all of the Ss pieces because it's
really easy in the world that I live in like
to not think of it thinking purely through
policy terms or purely through legislative.
I mean, I don't want to speak for the entire
town. No. Yes, absolutely. But I recognize
you know, thank you Vanessa, but one of the
most fascinating things and you totally get
it this year is the critical elements that
fell off the President's cornerstone legislative
achievement? Were the care piece, which was
both home care and child care was universal
pre K. And was the child Tax credit expanded
child tax credit? Which, oh, by the way, if
you look at the census data from yesterday
helped cut poverty uh in half, essentially
uh for child poverty in half, and is a demonstrably
an unequivocal, dramatic effect. And yet it
wasn't able to move through. And so if you're
the White House, you're saying, look, we got
prescription drug prices, ability, negotiate
on prescription drugs. When you talk about
the most significant dramatic climate investments
in the history, not just of this country,
but in the entire world, in terms of dollar
for dollar basis. Um, these are serious wins
for them that democrats have been pursuing
for a very long period of time. But when you're
looking at a very acute manner about what's
harming individuals in the current economy,
most some of the most critical components
of this plan uh fell off and just didn't have
the votes. And that's political reality. That's
policy reality in Washington, D. C. But that
is a very tough reality to grapple with when
you're the people that Vanessa is talking
to every day, let me bring in a question because
we're starting to get a few good questions
and keep them rolling everybody. But I might
have what have you take this one, paul, David
in South Carolina said I recently read the
cost of shipping containers has dropped 70%
since January. If so, when will this drop
be reflected in factored in the cost of items
on our shelves? I mean my gut reaction is
the inputs in shipping and in the supply chain
have been so screwed up for so many. We're
just still trying to find an equilibrium here.
What do you think Paul? I think it will take
unfortunately more time for some of these
massive declines in some of those input costs
to wind up being reflected when you go to
the store or when you're buying something
from amazon or your other favorite online
retailer of choice if it is an amazon. The
problem of course is that shipping is just
one component of the price of many consumer
goods. And as we saw in the C. P. I report
yesterday that led to that massive nearly
1300 points slide in the dow yesterday plunging
the dow food prices are still up sharply.
A lot of other commodity costs are going up
very dramatically. So even though shipping
costs are down and oil and other fuel prices
have come down, it's not as if everything
is going down in lock step. So there are just
so many components that make up the cost of
whatever you're buying at the supermarket
that it's gonna take a while I think for consumer
prices to come down. And and also you know,
there are a lot of legitimate questions and
concerns about companies needing to protect
their profit margins. I mean, Phil you joked
about Washington not being in step neither
is Wall Street with reality. A lot of times
you have Wall Street cheering bad economic
news and being upset about good economic news
because what they think it might mean for
inflation, the Fed, you have that to a certain
extent with corporate America and earnings
as well stocks, investors and stocks want
to see profits go up and how do you do that?
You try and keep pace with rising costs and
that sometimes means higher prices for goods
that consumers may not necessarily be able
to afford or be willing to pay in a tough
environment like this right now, economically,
let me bring in this question to you Phil
Mattingly from Joy in Ohio Joy asked this
what plans are in place to bring jobs back
to America and to keep the ones we have already.
This is, this is a question I've been hearing
really for decades, but it's kind of flipped
upside down right now. I mean, I don't know
what you're hearing, but I'm hearing Business
leaders start to say we need to talk about
immigration because we've got 11 million jobs
open in this country. We have a whole cohort
that's retiring, especially in nursing and
in engineering and in education and we need
more, we need more workers here, not more
jobs here and more workers here. So what what
is the, what is the scenario here? Yeah. Look,
let's start with the baseline that Joy lives
in the best state in the country. Um, and
that is important. Yes, Vanessa is there currently?
I'm sure it's not Iowa, I'm from Iowa and
you used to drive across the bridge and there
was a zipper zipper sign that said welcome
to Iowa, if you're looking for Ohio, turn
around basically. Yeah. The differences, we
score points in football games. Um, but the,
uh, sorry. Um, okay, to the actual question,
so there's two elements of this, right? Like
there's the broader kind of 30,000 ft policy
question. And I think immigration is where
you immediately had when you're looking, uh,
at one of the major drivers, major might be
a little a critical component of what we've
seen in terms of, uh, the employment picture
right now, there is no question. If you talk
to Christine, you do it every single day.
Vanessa paul, you guys do as well. You talk
to anybody in business, immigration is such
a central component of this. And it is such
a kind of, to their minds like a low hanging
fruit, we have to address this. Um, the fact
that we aren't is absurd. Let me tell you
from Washington D. C. It will not be addressed
and it will not be addressed anytime soon.
Uh, and, and we could do six hours as to why
that's the case. But I'm just telling you
right now. It is not on anybody's policy front
burner at the moment. One of the interesting
things and I mentioned the Ohio tie because
I was there last week with president biden
as he was opening a major intel factory um,
in just outside of columbus Ohio, there has
been a reassuring that we've seen and I know
you guys have picked up on it, Christine and
paul in terms of jobs at a level that we have
not seen in a long time. And where, where
I'm going with this is some of the legislation
that has passed Congress and has had like
an immediate effect, not just because of money
being shot out from the federal government,
but also because its ability to incentivize
private business both to invest and to expand
existing investments that will create thousands
of jobs here in specific communities in texas
and Ohio. Um other places is, there has been
a transition in terms of how some businesses
are looking at the United States, uh, the
incentives to actually build here, the incentives
to hire here. Now that doesn't match up the
scale of, of the kind of deficit right now
when it comes on the employment side of things,
but it's, it's an interesting trend line that
Christine. I don't know if you've ever seen
where we had, I think 300,000 jobs re short
over the course of the last year or two. And
I think that was a number that was kind of
like, wait, whoa, okay, well that's interesting.
Why is that happening? Um, and so to the extent
that trend continues and the extent that there's
policy ideas that can help accelerate that
trend and or maintain that trend, I think
is an interesting element as we all wait for
people to get it together on immigration.
We've all known. I mean, for years we've reported
on the concerns in Washington about the national
security implications, frankly of not having,
you know, your chip making abilities here
close at hand. And then look, we had a pandemic
where suddenly you can't get stuff, you can't
get important stuff to build things like fighter
jets. Right? And so, and plus you have rules
about what those where the sourcing for those
fighter jets. So we've found that, you know,
we really do have to double down on that,
reassuring some of those critical pieces.
And I think for the first time in my career,
I think I took a pandemic for anybody to get
really serious about it. Um, I want to go
to Tony and Georgia right now. Question their
thoughts on the housing market and any advice
to home buyers. I'll give this one to you,
Paula Monica. I mean, the housing market has
rolled over from that big, huge, just clearly
bubble it was in, but I don't know where it
goes from here. What do you think? Yeah, it
is a very difficult question, Christine and,
and obviously this is gonna sound a little
trite cliche. A lot of real estate professionals
talk about how the housing market isn't really
a national market, but a series of local markets
and in any individual market you're going
to see prices higher than they might be in
other geographic areas. But I think one thing
that isn't necessarily changing and you are
starting to see uh you know, I think more
and more workers really clamoring right now,
not necessarily just for higher wages as we've
all talked about, but more flexibility that
pandemic has taught. I think a lot of companies
and workers that if you are in particularly
a white collar job, someone like me who writes
stories and goes on tv, I'm not in a factory
and I don't need to be, yes, it's great when
I'm in the office, I'm here today, I'll be
here tomorrow, But I can work from home two
or three days a week and still be as productive
if not more so kids and pets notwithstanding
because I don't have a commute that I have
to worry about and I think that is something
that more Americans are going to demand that
they have that type of flexibility and I think
that's something that is going to be critical
and that will be, you know, I think key going
forward. Yeah, we're in the early innings
of these companies telling people they got
to come back, you know, physically at least
three days a week, some five days a week.
And I I don't know what the numbers are going
to show, but there are a lot of people who
say that's just not gonna work, that's just
not gonna work for them and they're more productive
at home and they don't want the, you know,
the 10 or eight or 10 commutes a week. So
we're on the subject of housing, an employer
that will be willing to keep them at home
if that's what they want. Totally, totally.
Um While we're on the subject, I guess of
housing, let's talk about interest rates because
the biggest, you know, Tony asked about Homebuyer
advice for homebuyers. Well, you know, interest
rates have risen, they were 2.87% I think
a year ago right now and they're at 6% right
now for a 30 year fixed rate mortgage. So
you can afford a little bit less or you can
you're gonna pay a lot more for the same size
house this year as as last year. So I guess
rapid fire here, you guys, what are each of
you thinking in terms of the Fed, from what
we've seen, I mean, higher interest rates
through the end of the year. I'll start with
you, Vanessa. Well, you know, I think we know
that they've been really focusing on sort
of this long term cooling of inflation. They've
been looking at CP I reports, I think the,
the signal that we're getting next week is
there's going to be an aggressive rate hike.
And I think that's probably the prognosis
until they feel like they've seen enough um
from data that suggests that the, that were
really cooling off with inflation. Of course,
of course, you mentioned, you know, at the
top with your question to me was this rail
strike. I mean, that could absolutely be the
wild card that could upend everything, especially
if it goes on. Um, you know, for a while.
But I think the Fed is probably going to remain
aggressive for as long as they feel like they
need to be in order to really see a pattern
of continued cooling um when it, when it comes
to inflation Phil I know you've watched this
interchange between Washington and Wall street,
the Fed, the administration, what, what are
you expecting in terms of higher rates down
the road? Yeah. Look, I've been in this game
long enough not to predict anything related
to rates until we get like the voice of God,
Wall Street Journal story four days before
the meeting ends. But like I think that now
that the point that we're at a baseline where
the next meeting, like 75 basis points is
baked in back to back, 75 basis point increases
is like bonkers to me. And I don't think people
necessarily kept grappled with that yet. And
the reason why I mentioned that is because
White House officials have been very clear,
unlike past administrations, both democrat
and republican, like they're not gonna say
a thing about the Fed, they recognize that
the Fed needs to do what the Fed has to do.
Uh but White House officials who have worked
uh the the entirety of their effort on the
economic side over the course of the last
1920 months has been to one prevent that scarring
that we saw in 0809, which they feel like
they've been successful at, but to really
kind of target the kind of lower core tiles
to if not raise people up at least keep them
uh floating to some degree through some very
difficult times. And they are keenly aware
that a soft landing is a very hard thing to
hit and that the people that are gonna get
hurt when rates increase the way that they're
going um are the very people that they've
really been trying to target uh their policies
towards. Again, you will never hear them talk
about talk bad about the Fed and the Fed should
be doing something different than it's doing.
But I think that the like all economists,
they are keenly aware that with aggressive
rate hikes that it's a necessity to address
inflation and I think has been very clear
about the realities and why uh in terms of
pursuing this policy, but there are very real
repercussions here. Uh, and I think that the
White House is very concerned about that for
a policy set. You know, paul, I mean, I guess
just how historic this has been these rapid
rate hikes and I guess we don't know how long
it's gonna take for them to start working.
Um, you know, I mean, that's the big question
and that's just a historic moment. I mean,
there's no, there's no precedent for, oh,
here's the formula for how to unwind unwind
all of the stimulus and rates are already
too low to begin with. I mean, it's just really
just a soup of uncertainty. Yeah, it is very
difficult. I do not envy jerome Powell or
little Brainerd or any of the other members
of the Fed who sit in these meetings and have
to make these decisions Christine because
again, you mentioned the late paul Volcker,
He obviously had an incredibly difficult job
in the 70s and early 80s to try and combat
inflation. That was historically bad at the
time and that we're now making comparisons
to. But he had the luxury of doing things
not necessarily in secret per se, but you
didn't have the focus on the Fed back then
at the same extent that you do now where every
single utterance by jerome Powell and other
important Fed members is scrutinized as if
it's some sort of biblical importance and
that you have all of these investors that,
you know, just on a knee jerk reaction will
make decisions that then impact. Unfortunately
what the Fed has to do because I mean, we
know that the Fed talks about how they have
two official mandates, which is price stability
and maximum employment and that's all about
the economy. But what the Fed will never say,
even though it's true, is that their third
unofficial mandate is to keep Wall Street
and other financial markets from freaking
out and trying to make them happy. So when
jerome Powell says that Jackson hole that
what the Fed is doing is going to cause some
pain and then the market implodes as a result
of those comments, Powell realizes that he
probably needs to be a little bit more careful.
I'd be very curious next week to see if in
his press conference he is not necessarily
so optimistic that he's, you know, buoyant
about the economic outlook. But if he maybe
is a little bit more measured in his tone,
it probably would be advisable to not use
the word pain multiple times again, except
even if it's true. But except except if if
you if you have a Fed that is very concerned
about being so far behind the curve for tightening.
Don't they want higher unemployment rate and
lower stock market. I mean, isn't that kind
of, I mean maybe that was very exactly what
Powell wanted. I don't know, Go ahead, Go
ahead Vanessa, I was just gonna tie it back
to the, to the real world impact because these
are the folks that I talked to every day kind
of tying in what paul and Phil were saying.
I mean, you know when, when you have these
aggressive rate hikes that really pushes mortgage
rates up and what we hear from first time
home buyers that have really saved for years
to try to buy their first home during the
pandemic um mortgage rates were so low and
then they really picked up very quickly and
just the couple $100 in in the amount that
it was gonna cost every month to pay for their
mortgage made a difference in them being able
to afford a home and not afford a home. And
then these folks are pushed back into the
rental market and the rental market is absolutely
insane right now, especially in coastal cities
where rents are breaking records left and
right, I mean middle class americans right
now are having trouble finding places to live
and finding affordable places to live. So,
you know, as as we're talking about these
interest rate hikes and what the Fed is planning
on doing, I mean there is, you know, some
pain that comes along with that when you talk
when you put it into practice and and the
fact that that people are just trying to get
ahead, they're just trying to buy a home and
they think they can do and then just one number
moves a little bit and they're at the game
and the and you know, folks are folks are
concerned what should they do? They don't
know, they're waiting it out like the rest
of us. I know you mentioned rents, rents,
I'm just looking at my notes from yesterday's
CPI. I report because I I broke that on new
day and rent year over year rent increases
6.2% which is not as bad as the as the grocery
number except rent is non negotiable. Like
the grocery numbers, you've seen people trade
down, you've seen them move to different cuts
of meat, you've seen them switch. You know,
there's there's some, unless you're the lowest
quintile of earners and as we know, inflation
really hurts the poorest people the worst.
There's no flexibility for them. But for a
lot of families, they're making these changes
in trading down. But on rent you can't really
do that and and that you can't just, you know,
flip where you're living over the next week.
So I think that rent one is something that
shelter inflation is something that continues
to be a problem. I want to read another question
Phil Mattingly from Edmond Edmond in Illinois,
there are stories about increased profits
for C. E. O. S and skyrocketing higher education
prices. Okay. Two story, two problems clearly
um is Congress doing anything to investigate
and put pressure on companies for unfair practices
like collusion and an overall lack of innovation.
I feel like there's kind of two questions
in there. Um, on the one hand, you had Congress,
you know, you have the administration rather
step into forgive some student loan debt.
That doesn't solve the problem of sky high
tuition. Right. On the other hand, you do
have corporate profits that are still strong
and corporate ceo salaries are still very,
very good and companies are able to pass along
higher prices to consumers to protect their
shareholders. Is there is there a role for
Washington in that, or is that just capitalism?
Yeah, I mean, it's not really a Congress roll,
goodness gracious. You don't want lawmakers
trying to figure out in the way it's policy
things must not kidding. Um, but I think the
difference right now, I think that in past
administrations and this and Christine, you
know, this very well, um, antitrust policy
has become a really central element of, uh,
some progressive politics, democratic politics
generally, and to be frank in an area where
it actually measures a little bit bipartisan,
um, and some republican circles as well. Um,
and so to the extent there's a role when it
comes to, when he was talking about kind of
collusion, that's not necessarily the word
I would use, but in terms of consolidation,
in terms of market dynamics and power, um,
you have seen a more aggressive, at least
in tone posture from the administration's
FTC, including a chairwoman who comes from
a world of being more aggressive on this side
of things. The department's antitrust team
has made clear that they want to be more aggressive.
So I think that's one area you look at and
I'm not really sure that I'm getting it necessarily
ceo salary part of things so much as I am.
Um, market consolidation and market power
based on a few very large companies, um, on
student loans. Look whatever your views are
of the decision to forgive $10,000 for individuals
making under 100 25 K or 20,000 fewer power
grant recipient that took out federal loans.
You cannot deny the fact that it changed absolutely
aerodynamics in terms of the overall cost
of education, um, in college. And I think
that that is even folks that were enormously
supportive of what President biden did, um,
acknowledged that there is a huge issue and
likely a huge bubble here that needs to somehow
some way be deflated. Um, because frankly,
as somebody with four kids, I have no freaking
idea how I'm going to afford school. So, and
I know I'm not the only one that we just had
1/4 Like we don't even know, it just kind
of happens. Well, I have three and I am, I've
been saving in 5, 29 college savings plans
since they were like, you know, since they
were born. And I still, I look at this landscape
and I look at this reach school rat race that
people are in, You know, where they're trying
to figure out how to, I mean, I went to a
state school and I'm very pro state schools.
I don't know about you guys, but I mean, I
I just don't think this bubble's gonna pop
before I'm actually paying for this tuition.
So I mean, I don't know how people, I I don't
know how people do it and I'm going to learn
pretty quickly here how people are gonna do
it. How old is your oldest feel? seven. So
we got some time. I'm hoping the entire marketplace
just inverts in the course of the next decade.
I just need an electrician. I just need one
electrician out of these three boys. And I
think that will be okay. I think your kids,
your kids may go to the same school. Are they
in high school yet to the same school that
I went to in our time. So I have one in your
high school. In fact, I just did back to school
night last night and I was thinking of you
if I can, if I can have one that I know I'm
public schools, I'm all about public schools,
All about state schools. Let's talk a little
bit more about the federal minimum wage is
a question here from someone asking if there's
any hope of the federal minimum wage increasing
paul, I'll give that to you. When was like,
when was the last time they raised in 97?
I think it's officially, it's 7 25 an hour,
but a lot of states have already done this
on their own, haven't they? Yeah, they have.
And I think that's something that we will
probably see. Okay guys, I'm not a conspiracy
theorist, but the higher education gods just
shut us down when we were complaining about
paying for college. I think that might be
what happened. I'm just teasing. I'm I really
am just using I don't know what happened.
A little bit of a technical a technical glitch
there, but paul finish your thought. Yeah,
I think what is going to be very challenging
for many consumers right now is paying bills
when, as we all know, inflation has raised
the cost of just about everything. And you
have people with sometimes multiple minimum
wage jobs and that that's enough. So even
though the states, many states have done a
good job of raising the minimum wage, I think
it would behoove Congress and the White House
to try and work together in order to do something
from a federal level. I'm not so naive enough
to suggest that Washington is going to suddenly
have its kumbaya moment and get something
done. But stranger things have happened recently
and Phil can probably talk more about that
than I can. Yeah. So the minimum wage, it
seems like the states have really taken companies
actually have taken the lead on this. I mean,
I was talking to some executives at walmart,
you know, earlier this year, who were saying
they made all these investments in the front
end, you know, which is pay for their workers,
um, and raising their minimums because they
can't, they just don't want to be this turnover,
that it cost them to turn people over. So
there is a free market capitalist case for
the market, raising the minimum wage on its
own. Yeah, and I think why this is such an
interesting moment. You remember, there was
a huge fight about this at the beginning of
this Congress, at the beginning of President
Obama's time in office. Um, and, and I won't
take you down the Senate procedural rabbit
holds as to why it ended up not being able
to move through. But the reality was doesn't
have votes, doesn't have enough democratic
votes to be able to move through, let alone
uh, 60 votes in the Senate. What's fascinating
in this moment, you guys got into this a little
bit earlier is that there is just a, like
labor has power now uh, at a level that I
don't think we've seen in a long time and
it's not just because there is such a, such
a tight labor market, um, there is a and Vanessa
is dealing with this right now on a day to
day basis in Cleveland in terms of, uh, you
have a very pro Union White House, you have,
uh, probably the most pro union president,
self proclaimed pro labor president in the
last several decades, maybe even longer at
the same time. You have these market dynamics,
um that, well, this is not a reflection of
my whether or not the uh, minimum wage should
be raised or not. It is just a very interesting
moment to watch how businesses are responding
to it, how the private sector is responding
to it, but also how unions, which for decades
have been kind of decimated, particularly
at the state level. Um, have a kind of new
sense of power and strength. And I don't think
it's a sense, I think it's very real. Um,
and we're watching that play out across the
country and not just in this rail issue. Um,
and what that means going forward in terms
of the relationship between business and labor,
which is always a little tense and contentious.
Um, but, but how that develops in the dynamics
play out over the course of the coming years.
Yeah, let's go through that. You've got T.
O go ahead. But I want to, I want to ask you
about teachers, right, nurses, rail workers,
baristas. I mean right down the line, you're
seeing all these industries are either starting
to organize for unions or unions that are
getting a little more aggressive. Yeah, I
think we're sort of in the year years of the
union. I mean we have amazon Starbucks unionizing,
becoming successful at that. Um, I just want
to just latch onto the minimum wage. The folks,
I talked to talk about minimum wage and then
livable wage, like $15 an hour for folks is
not really a livable wage, especially if you
live in a major city like new york or L. A.
Or even Chicago. So I just think, you know,
we're talking about minimum wage would be
great to get it up, you know, to the federal
level of $15 an hour. But that's like, that's
like a benchmark for people. They're like,
great, thank you for getting us there. Where
can we go coming back? Um, you know, to the
sort of moment of unions, I think every union
is looking at pat past unions that were successful
in their negotiations. You know, if we look
at sort of across the industries, um, we look
at Hollywood with the stagehands unions there,
they were successful in their fight to get
what they want. Starbucks same thing, amazon
same thing, Kellogg's workers, same thing,
john Deere, same thing. These unions who are
fighting against these big companies ultimately
ended up get a lot of what they want. So I
think unions are looking behind them and thinking,
well, hey, if they got it, why can't we get
it? And I think that's what's playing out
right now, especially with the rail workers,
there's a lot of dynamics at play, but with
the rail workers, they feel like, well, wait
a minute we have bided our time. We are at
the end of our contract. Why are we going
to give up now? We have the power, Yeah, the
roster being on call, seven days a week. And
the fact that the rail operators have made
so much money during the pandemic, I mean,
that seems to be one of the many sticking
points here. So let's wrap it up, each of
you. I want to talk, I mean, we're 50 some
days away from midterm elections. Um, you
know, Paula Monica. The economic picture is
still very murky. The state of the union is
id, I don't know for the economy, but people
have jobs, you know, people are still savings
rates still higher than it was, you know,
pre pandemic. Um, the stock market's down
sharply this year, but that's after being
up 20 some percent, several years in a row.
So give me a sense of the headwind or tailwind
of the economy for the midterms or is it not
clear? I think it's still not 100% clear statement
things are changing so rapidly. It's such
a dynamic market right now that think about
it just a few months ago and most of the political
stories were along the lines of how bad is
it going to be for president biden and the
democrats in november. You know, predictions
of, you know, red rave, read whatever you
want to use whatever you're now no choices
for how republicans could just take much more
control in Congress and and now all of a sudden
the president has had some key legislative
victories. The job market remains strong,
inflation is still a significant problem for
the White House, but obviously the stock market
has rebounded from the depths of where it
was, you know, the middle of the year. So
all of a sudden, I don't think it's as certain
through it, your world versus wade being overturned
as well. What that might mean to get a more
energized Democratic voter base to the polls.
I don't think it's clear anymore that, you
know, president biden is in as much trouble
as it seemed a few months ago. But again,
the caveat is, it's september 14th, there's
still a lot of time and a lot of headlines
to be made between now and early november
that could shift the balance into either the
left or right direction. You know, Phil one
of my sources who covers Wall Street and Washington
and that intersection was scratching his head
saying, you know, I thought the republicans
would be able to make hay with these inflation
figures this week, you know, and instead lindsey
Graham is coming out and talking about an
abortion limit, like what? You know, that
he couldn't believe that they weren't really
just zeroing in on inflation in the economy.
Yeah, I I texted a republican pal of mine
who's working on a campaign. The link to kind
of the story about Graham introducing it and
he just responded, nightmare, like total total
nightmare. Um look, paul paul has a great
point. Like if you want to know how the midterms
are gonna end, you know, talk to somebody
who's living on november 9th, I have no flipping
idea how this is actually going to go when
it comes to the economy. Tell me where gas
prices are and tell me whether or not there
is a trend line of the seller inflation, right?
So they have an actual story to tell again,
kind of that Reagan thing. And then the also
White House line is if you tell me where gas
is, I will tell you what the university of
michigan consumer sentiment is without fail
every single month. So, those are things,
I think the two critical things on the economy
and I think to paul's point the bigger question
right now, I think everybody, the smartest
people in both parties are trying to figure
out is Does the Supreme Court decision, does
the legislative success, do these change?
What seems to be pretty rigid dynamics? Not
just in this midterm, but in every midterm
save for a couple over the course of the last
70 years. I don't think that's a great answer
that yet. Yeah. And I guess vanessa wrap it
up for us. I mean, I guess it's the direction
of things over the next 50 days, not necessarily
the level of things over the next 50 days.
Yeah. And I think there's certainly so many
wild cards. I mean the war, the war in Ukraine,
you know, turn the tide dramatically for the
economy. Um you know, you have this rail strike
looming, that could change things. I really
hate to be doomsday, but you could have a
really bad hurricane, you know, hit hit the
south. Um you know, around anywhere down south
and that could wipe out, you know, anything
that has to do with oil and gas and that could
really bring gas prices up. I just think,
I don't want, I'm sort of with, you know,
with all you guys, like I'm not predicting
anything so much can change, but I think that
the things to look at it, where are we with
inflation and then, you know, the roe versus
wade situation, is that gonna play 50 days
from now? Yeah, we'll have a lot to talk about.
Hopefully we'll be able to do it again. Everybody.
Thanks so much for joining me. This has been
a great citizen by CNN conversation. Even
with our technical glitches everyone keep
saving for college, especially Phil Mattingly
will set up a go fund me for filling his kids.
Um you can register for next Wednesday's citizen
policies that impact the midterms. That's
gonna be seven eastern. That's Casey Hunt
moderating. It's a conversation with Gloria
Gloria Borger David chalian and jasmine. Right?
It's gonna be fantastic. Have a great day.
Thank you everybody.